[Music]
good evening the last thing anyone needs
from me right now is a reminder of how
the world and all our lives have changed
over the last couple of months but I'd
like to begin with my solidarity for
anyone worried about loved ones or who
has lost them in recent times even in
these days of social distancing self
isolation and all these bitter pills
words and practices you are not alone
with virtually but not actually together
some of us have sufficient health food
shelter and internet access to be able
to engage in this discussion and that
places us under greater Duty constantly
to think about those who don't our
response to this global pandemic here
and internationally will either
exacerbate every inequality
inconsistency and injustice in how we
share the planet or begin to bring us
closer together the world before covet
19 is past the status quo ante not an
option I know that this brings terror to
some hope to others and a strange
cocktail of both too many these are
hugely dangerous and difficult times but
I believe that a combination of
innovation imagination empathy and
millennia of experience and learning
will help us find our way through and
any brighter future must have human
rights values at its center we've called
this talk looking down on human rights
the cause of its ambiguity or at least
the choice that presents between
discarding values or being guided by
them even in times of emergency just as
the word security conjures either
incarceration or comfort lockdown can
signify protection all prison depending
on our circumstances attitude and the
practical approach of a
in power
so what do I mean by human rights values
well firstly I don't mean unfettered
freedom in reality there's never been
such a thing unrestrained Liberty for
the wolf looks rather less attracted to
the lamb even a so-called free market
requires a great deal of rules of the
game to prevent people rubbing and
cheating each other to bind them to the
deals they strike in good faith prevent
cartels and monopolies that eat the
choice and competition on which the
market is supposed to depend and that's
before you even get into debates about
employment consumer environmental
protections the functioning of the free
market has always required significant
regulation to keep it that way and thus
a mystery of democracy what's the value
of Elections if people don't have the
votes or are intimidated against using
it what if the winner-take-all
government were to use its massive
majority one year to censor and silence
critics including opponents or even to
postpone further elections just like the
market democracy is capable and eating
itself and descending into something
quite different so some of our rights
and freedoms notably to voting free
elections associate with each other and
speak sometimes privately and sometimes
in public are almost the equivalent of
fair competition rules for democracy at
the most basic level each human being
needs a great deal of freedom protection
and nurturing to survive let alone
thrive our human rights tradition
recognizes this and our essence as
amazing individual creatures but social
creatures nonetheless we need protection
from interference intrusion oppression
and cruelty but also from infection
isolation destitution and starvation and
ASRA
elected in the name of this festival we
must have light or at least the
opportunity to find it in fuller lives
of the hearts mind body and soul you in
dream of inviting a guest into your home
to share in the food and shelter but not
the music and discussion attempts to
dismiss either civil and political
freedoms or social economic and cultural
rights are just as foolish nor is this a
vain attempt at eliminating risk from
our lives the wartime generation
responsible for the settlement knew all
too well how impossible that would be
instead they were concerned with valuing
life and not allowing the powerful to
take reckless risks with the lives of
others post-world war ii human rights
are a legal and ethical framework of
rights freedoms and protections all
springing from the idea that all human
lives matter and that we're born equal
in our dignity and worse thirdly it's so
important to emphasize that this is not
just about law Human Rights values form
part of our ethical and political
thinking as well so those who say the
problem with demanding rights is that it
avoids responsibilities couldn't be more
wrong you're right can't be delivered
without my obligation to respect it it's
of course correct that in law states
have the ultimate responsibility for
protecting the human rights of their
people but these rights can never be a
practical reality without a great deal
of legal and moral responsibility on all
people as well take the rare and
absolute right not to be subject to
inhuman and degrading treatment or
torture
that's not just about military and
police personnel the world over being
prohibited from behaving that way nor is
it merely about States providing and
enforcing adequate criminal laws against
violence and sexual offenses it's about
how we treat each other when no one's
looking and the vulnerable can't
complain in the home hospital care home
police station nursery they'll never be
enough legislators or police officers on
the planet to deliver human rights by
law alone and even if there were who
would protect us from them so those who
attack human rights for blurring the
line between law and politics are also
missing the point there has never been a
bright line between law politics
economics culture and religion for that
matter human rights values that both
shaped by them and animators are the
same there are of course perfectly
proper debates to be had about how best
to promote inspire deliver or in for
certain outcomes at certain times
sometimes the leader you need is
encouragement sometimes investment
sometimes hard-edged law including a
range of sanctions often it's a
combination of all three so we have a
long developed and hard-won system of
international human rights
it contains checks and balances and
rights and freedoms for our civil and
political social economic and cultural
life at home work in our democracy in
wider world it doesn't solve all our
complex problems but it gives us a
compass to help in their navigation and
some tests for a proposed solutions so
far so good
so why still so controversial in my
experience everyone loves certain human
rights their own its other people's
protections that are sometimes somewhat
harder to swallow my speech is free
yours is a little more expensive
I want the right to travel and entertain
myself unhindered even during a global
pandemic even poisoning the planet in
the process I'll take my own risks thank
you as I do when I drink or smoke or eat
unhealthy food in spite of the advice to
the country that's surely my right as a
Freeborn Englishman well yes to a degree
but we've long said that you can't drive
the car or fly the plane whilst
intoxicated because of the risk that you
inflict upon other people we've more
recently prevented you from smoking in
certain closed environments for a
similar reason and now just because you
feel the reckless invincibility of a
lifetime of privilege that doesn't mean
that we shouldn't balance your right to
roam against the rights of others around
you and especially the health workers
professionally and ethically bound to
pick up the pieces when you're hitherto
considerable luck all that of others
around you at the roulette table runs
out the reason why human rights have
often proved so controversial is that
they belong to everyone equally whether
we like them or not
and must be applied with an even hand to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a I dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas